my name is the moderator or
interpretation about the beauty of
evasion biodiversity in that discussion
we talked about how in Asia as being the
second largest by diversity countries in
the world after Brazil in order to
preserve the illusion by Omaha City we
need to engage and all the governments
but also the business leaders the local
people because the local people have
already implemented local values to
preserve the biodiversity in Indonesia
and action should be taken up not only
at the national level but also at
international level
now I'm going to answer a question
something at my journey to Festa about
how can we tackle climate change in East
Asia is the beautiful expired this year
I believe we need to empower local
people or in the future and the special
you know because they're the one who's
going to face the language change in the
future and then by doing this it means
that we need to make use of the social
medium of the order technology industry
or IT importance to spread the spirit
and so that now he has you know push the
agenda to be able to finish in time by
the government's in the world in that
way he finally sent an answer or
solutions in order to attack
I'm shades to the future